plans and when we first rocked up as
well he was trying to hunt a warthog so
a very hungry boy and another hungry boy
is only clue let's go down and see him
in Juma good afternoon all and welcome
to the Sunset Drive my name is Ollie and
joining us behind the camera is David we
are coming to you live from the western
flanks of the kruger national park in
the sabi sands in south africa so for
any questions and comments you send them
on hess takes a file I have on Twitter
look at the view amazing so my plan for
this afternoon is to go and check what's
going on and what's happening with my
capitated of chicks because it's been
two days now not knowing what happened
we had a storm so I think they are just
still good who knows and I'm moving
forward moving forward and see whether I
find them so I'll be mostly on the
western flanks of the of the reserve so
that's where I will find who Komori
so where you find shedule ooh I've been
seen since she dude since I started here
it's a fine life so that's why I always
make time to be on the western side
oh girl thank you thank you these are my
happy socks they're in South Africa we
call them happy socks and today they
will be give me luck to find this
rosette it gets who Thank You God you
know you have to try all the spices when
you're here in the bush you don't have
to wear brown black or or khaki all the
time must must must have this mix
channel
so while I'm relying on my socks to have
that lucky
luck let's go to Tristan for an
introduction
well I agree you've got to try
everything in order to get some luck and
so hopefully only has done all the good
things for us to get luck this afternoon
say boy are we going to be lucky this
afternoon say when I we're not lucky
yesterday afternoon well I suppose we
were all right I mean we are dying a
dinner was very active said we can't
complain too much but hopefully as we
are gains get a lot luckier this
afternoon but as early said my name is
Tristan and on camera as I've just said
is Sebastian the softs you know
hopefully we are going to be able to
find things that we are looking for and
so we're going to be looking for really
anything of interest at this stage I'm
in the area around where Herbie had
tracks for sundean Columba this morning
you said to me that's is convinced that
they somewhere in the the block off to
my left hand side but obviously during
the course the day they might have moved
around and there's a few little mud
wallows on this road that we're on so
you're just checking those out I'm just
seeing if maybe any of them came for a
drink during the course of the day
otherwise we'll kind of hit we had the
last tracks and go and scratch around
yeah he's convinced that there's
something around here that they're kind
of hanging about for and so let's see
what we can try and kind of locate and
see whether or not he's right but that's
gonna be the plan for the afternoon is
just to take whatever comes our way
really and hope that eventually our luck
will kick in and we'll be able to see
something of interest it's a nice
weather this officer I mean it's not
like yesterday where it was quite cold
and rainy today at least is a fairly
nice temperature and perfect kind of for
a game Drive Linda are you asking about
my lucky socks and are you asking at a
very bad corner hold on two seconds
it means just get around this corner
before I crash the car but I am NOT some
wearing shorts today so generally when I
wish sports I wear shorts socks so these
are not really lucky socks but there we
go
just try and carry on driving or would
you this is if you tick bites there as
well you can tell it's summer so there's
lots of tick bites all over my legs but
yes I am a fashion icon what can I say
Emma this is the way it is and one must
have
Feli which is a type of shoe that we
have our chair in South Africa and tick
bites and then you are from the bush in
Samba anyway there we go
so no no proper lucky socks today we're
gonna try something different yesterday
I wore my lucky socks we didn't really
get that lucky so we're gonna do go with
a little bit of a different kind of way
of doing things this afternoon
now we Gaines have to also turn around
and go the opposite way because we have
a roadblock that we're not technically
allowed to look at so I will leave them
to themselves because they seem as
though they are settling in arguments at
the stage
right now that we've turned around I'll
let them do their thing
thank you all the viewers apparently are
wishing me luck
well hopefully we will have some luck
somewhere here sits a little spotted cat
and I say little because the lumber is
still small and so hopefully she's going
to stop being a rebel and start actually
coming out and showing herself over the
course of the next little bit good now
we're gonna go and have a little look
and we're gonna go see what's happening
in the meantime though let's send you
back across to Wally and see what he's
managed to find with his lucky socks yes
we found this cute dwarf moose
hello this one is photogenic you can
tell because others are running away
from us and this one just stood there
waiting patiently to be live hello
you're live do you believe that I can
see this is a baby planting is an adult
looking at the size of it we have the
second one they also want to be on
camera oh these were they live they live
in this dam at mounds they invade this
pyramid Mountain killing whatever they
can find in they then they live in peace
is a smaller small Mongoose you can find
here in Toomer though they are really
cute hey and look at their fur it so
it's so shiny more especially when the
Sun shines upon it a little bit of
scratching day
and you can think these animals for this
Mongoose are lazy you owe me maybe they
are cowards but these ones are yes
because they can kill a venomous huge
snake because there was this one
instance when I saw them giving not a
fully-grown rock python afghan rock
python and that's when I started to
respect these moves they are the best
and they live in groups
well then nice exciting to start the
drive with it was my lucky socks and now
it is mongooses oh this guy doesn't want
to go anyway he just wants to be on
camera can see he's moving around around
then he gives us this quick look and
then he removes a cane and what's so
great about this mongoose is that they
they live in a group way to a male and a
female are only allowed to breed so the
other members of the group there they
only help with raising the young ones so
if they want you to mate and then they
have to leave the group and start their
own family
and they don't stay in this helmet
mounds for life
crusty ones do you want to know that I
really related to rodents
I don't think so that they're related to
rodents because their upper lip it's not
divided into two mongooses we found here
from the water mongoose that's so hard
to see we find the slander Mongoose
that's one we normally see and these
mongooses also the banded mongoose we
find around here but those ones are also
CS to find
and let me communicate with them a
little bit dismiss a sarah saying it
says he he loved his little creatures
yes I also loved him
they are so interesting to watch you can
watch them the whole day and more
especially when they start communicating
with the yellow-billed hornbill before
they they go out of this termite mound
they need to to listen to that horn PL
calling first and then it tells them
that there's no danger outside or just
around the amount they don't just pop
out of it a madman just like that they
wait for that bird
I'm sure this one hoop is starving
tonight because some are are walking
around all over the place trying to find
some food and this one is busy getting
photogenic here with us
Julie well suno is the group of Monk was
really cold a business I've had that
that it's called a business so I haven't
checked that out but I think it's called
a business because you know these guys
are always busy that's why and they're
busy working so I think it is called a
business I'll check that one out
it's hot today
oh it's hot so where are you wait where
did you leave just around this this
bushes here David do you see one of them
they've left so the attire of the camera
so let's press forward and see whether
we can find the cat but remember we'll
start with the chick it's not far away
from us I can say it's about 400 meters
I'm crossing fingers that those cheeks
are safe
sometimes you have to rely on luck in
this place because during this time of
the year it's thick
do you ever look for for rent insects
stay your is that starer sorry if I
didn't get your name right uh you know
when it comes to insects you really I
really not love to see insects and this
cool and creepy crawly insect but you
know you is not a great time to look for
insects great time to look for insects
it's in the morning so we'll find all
these beautiful spiders and it's small
insects
and most of the insects dia they are new
to me because insects for me at
difficult because they they are so
plenty and they looked so different so
you have to learn a lot about them to
master them move west with my eyes
put the cap a little bit down
so while I'm driving to go and find out
what's wrong with what happened with my
check let's go to pet in the Mara
well yes must be very similar between
here ahjumma right now as well because
the Sun is most definitely a shining so
I'm just making my way through here I've
heard the Oh Lulu looks around in this
area so I'm just slowly cruising through
they were only briefly seen but I am
just keeping an eye out just in case as
I am bumbling about this afternoon
oh now I do have to apologize to
everyone yesterday I had a little bit of
a slip-up I'd said that the giraffes
gestation period was 22 months but it's
the African elephant
that's gestation period is 22 months
giraffes is only 15 I did know that I
perhaps it was because I was in the hawk
sighting it was a giraffe and two
elephants perhaps where this slip-up
came from but just a bit of a mix-up
there and I do apologize for that one
but yeah little bit confused
so yeah that that hunts or the hunting
leopard yesterday was very cool we ended
up just sitting up in a tree Alice I
don't really have any updates on me or
Lulu they haven't really been sighted
too much and since that fight with the
river pride so yeah I don't really know
I've I've seen two of the females myself
and I've only ever heard of two other
Thema
no sorry for other females being seen
the mother though of the Cubs that were
lost hasn't been seen since she took
that nasty tumble after being forced
over the cliff by the rest of the pride
well no you're not the rest of the ole
ole ole pride the rest of the river
pride
but yes I would like to catch up with
them see see how they are all getting
along all of those young boys
is a beautiful a beautiful daylight wise
everyone is sad that they didn't catch
the leopard oh yes I was sad that you
guys couldn't watch along with me it was
epic it was actually quiet epic he was
looking very hungry and just cruising
through the burnt patch and so I guess
that was why he was actually had a bit
of a theory as to why he was there
obviously the burn patch being
recolonized by herbivores has brought
him in and because the grass is still
very short he's seeing a lot of food but
they're also seeing him and so he was
looking hungry but also constantly
constantly trying to hunt something so I
think there's just too much temptation
but not enough cover at the moment for
the poor thing but I did hear that he
moved on well I'm assuming it's him that
moved on they said another male leopard
moved on past the river yesterday and
was looking hungry and I think actually
attacked her a gory tuna village that's
what I heard anyway that was the
direction that that the leopard was
hunting when we left it I mean heading
not hunting when we left it was kind of
moving and then sitting moving sitting
moving seeing set up in a tree for a
while and then it just went flat under a
tree and that was the last I saw of him
so I'm just coming up at the moment get
a vantage point
oh I shall continue your on searching
about see whether I can come up with and
in the meantime let's catch up with
ollie see how his search is going born
inside I think they're gone he has the
nest it's alone
no heartbeat no chicks nothing
moment of silence for that
yes born inside I think they went for
shopping or else they've been devoured
by a predator ha let's go it's so
heartbreaking you know
and I've checked and checked there is
nothing and I don't think it flew off
because it was young for it to fly
and those were were to cape petrel Taos
chicks
Ilyn what is the survival rate of chicks
of this caped 8 mm I think it's up to
70% if I that's my theory because
there's a lot of them they are not like
other periods we have a lot of capital
terms in there in the reserve so and
outside the reserve there's a lot of
them but these ones were not likely
huh hopefully I'll get another nest and
follow it because it so great seeing
these little chicks growing from few
days old until now
I'm so heartbroken but we have a lot to
see in this place don't give up
Red's 30 someone used the eggs for
scrambled eggs no no ha and remember
those chicks they are vulnerable and we
they are born altricial so they are born
helpless they are fed by the parents so
that makes them an easy meal to
predators like snakes
the birds
and cats
so I'm just approaching cuckoo Morris
cuckoo Morris territory a lot more wants
to know how long will it take for the
parents to lay another eggs uh I'm not
sure with that but what I know about the
Capitol towers they they lay eggs
throughout the year they don't have a
specific season to lay eggs you can find
eggs in winter I've seen that at home
you can find the eggs in in spring
summer and autumn does you know they're
feeling strategy they they can
tim is always said just like time way we
lost scuba scuba yes I'm really sad
because I've known those two chicks
which is bony and hide few days after
they were born until the time where they
started develop feathers like real
feathers like adult fitness and now they
are porn oh here's a junction and the
western boundary this is the place where
we have to check for tracks good places
to check for tracks
this is Hoku morris territory Okumura
it's a male leopard that had a territory
around this area it's about seven years
old
ah FC is that from you or from the
viewers that you need them tracking tips
for the week
tracking tips for the week hmm as I
always say it's nothing as I always say
I go back to Reseda we have something
yeah it's fine yeah I'll answer that we
have a dove this is a laughing tough and
it is a different species not the same
once as the ones we lost their checks
this one has small chicks they define
size and it's nested it's more than the
one we saw that earlier on
David let's move forward I feel so
heartbroken when I see at our fiction
that's because of the situation we are
we are in right now
we lost the Dove chicks and then we are
looking at this stuff now it breaks my
heart you know oh we have another
birthday the receipt earthy is it oh
it's gone oh let's push forward davis ET
maybe we'll see it it still they yeah
and they thought it was uh oh it's gone
a lot more
oh sorry David
a lot more you always surprised how
quickly tabs are what the periods are
the only things we can see right now but
the thing is they are not stationary
they are flying around I'm trying to get
a nice fit for you
oh yeah oh we have something yet let me
press forth a little bit
yeah on your left we have one of my
favorite animals they're gone those are
the warthogs let me sneak 4d they see
they can see the tail is up me that's
the signal to the young ones and other
members of the group where they when
they change the direction ah what talks
they are always up to something
you get to be like you one day
oh when you have a sighting like five
minutes or ten minutes sighting with
them you then you are the luckiest
person because they are always moving
around
oh look what we have hey David let me go
back a little bit
something is happening there he is he
said James says who Kimura people at
this weekend oh yeah in the industry no
even supported who Kamali he they we
have a community nests spiderweb and
then just right next to it we we have a
nest a in that nest I think it belongs
to a blue X bill because we can see the
the cross type of cross it's a blue seed
grass or in there there's lots and lots
and lots hundreds and hundreds of
spiders in they and this is the smallest
nest of I've seen in the reserve of sin
huge nest of this virus oh what's that
the grasshopper cricket of some sort
and this nest Commission has spiders
they can even kill birds wild how many
spiders are in the I really don't know
but there's a there's a lot of them in
they if the spider nest is active it can
be up to hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of spiders in they wait for the
prey to be caught in that web then you
will see them in action
there's a lot of them and there's this
one interesting thing I've read about
this community nurse or spiders is that
if maybe an adult dies they will eat
they will eat the adult they eat one
another I don't know why and how it's
hot I'm sorry about that
yeah but I'm using my path here hmm
spiders let's move forward
David yeah
and they can build a huge nest that they
can catch a big breed like this
and Jen huh there are lot of spiders
around yes and I always love this season
oh look at that you see that David mm mg
anyways talking about spiders
look at that cold and web without seeing
a spider you can really tell this is a
called an OP web you can see the
reflection from the sunlight it turns
this weapon to cold
nature kill wants to know will a bird
eat these spiders I've never seen
appeared eating a spider but I think
they might in it so remember these
spiders they're venomous and then I
really don't know if a period devour a
spider that is venomous who will die or
not but I'm sure some samples or some
few pets they do eat venomous spiders
and look how big is this web
it's huge
Linda yes it looks like hard work indeed
but spiders they can do this thing
easily because they can construct in the
web their size in a day
and you won't believe that this silk
came out of that small abdomen day this
email day David or maybe it's another
spider web they go and look the distance
from one tree to another tree
spiders are really incredible penny
wants to know are they really venomous
they are venomous to their prey not to
to us human but I'm sure this thing will
give you this nasty pain but the one
killers they only kill their prey and
look how it's moving quick I think it's
something they it's even something
it's not eating something then it simply
means it's still constructing or
reinforcing some parts of its web
oh do you think that's is that a mirror
on top of that abdomen
David you see something profound easily
on top of that abdomen I think yeah
that's a male
yes it is made you can see the size
difference between the female and the
male
and that guy is in is in trouble if he's
not away because he's he's going to be
devoured by this huge female
let's press forward and see what else we
can find
while it cold and up web spider Lisa
once you know that do you have more than
one male in the web I good yeah yeah
let's get another look maybe you will
see another male because I've only saw
one male in one web maybe after mating
if she eats the male and then another
meal will come who knows maybe it's the
5th or 30th male in this web who knows
because the males they probably look the
same and look at that the carcass is
David do you see that is it the string
with painting yeah those are the insects
that despite our eight
mmm these are leftovers you can see they
they've been wrapped around by with the
sock this is still she's still
constructing reinforcing everything II
oh this is beautiful
early once you know - this golden orb
spiders share these work with other
species of spiders I don't know what
happened was I was with you David a few
days ago we saw this op web spider
building constructing the web next to
this other called an OP web spider so I
think they can be next to each other but
not in the same web they only share
these webs with the males this female
the one we are looking at right now it's
a female because of the size David let's
move
I'm still in the western part of the
reserve but not in the boundary I'm
still going to the boundary
whereas who Kimura hiding maybe he's
waiting wherever he is but you know
after the rains we like kids the kids
they have to mark their territory again
because the rains wash away their scent
so maybe we'll be lucky this afternoon
and see who Kimura marking his territory
rido new viewer where where I am in the
moment I'm in South Africa western
flanks of the Kruger National Park sabi
sands and a beautiful reserve called
Juma private game I'm in the western
part of the reserve
oh it's grass thick
I had a long segment hey so but for now
let's go to the morrow it seems like
they're up and running
ah we do I apologize everybody we had a
little bit of a gremlin issue so he had
to go back to camp and get that fixed up
but never to worry all's well that ends
well and we are ready to head back out
again and so I'll be restarting my
search not that I was really searching
for anything anyway well obviously I'm
searching for something but no plans as
I said earlier so just cruising on down
the hill just well I'm up here I'm just
gonna have a look at with my binoculars
I think I see something
that's a boulder just a boulder all
right now you have a little bit of break
up as I come down it the hill a little
bit but I want more waste at the bottom
so it shouldn't be too much if any
so please do bear with me
it's such a beautiful way to started
here's the defecate right at the start
of the death - can he get some look over
the landscape and always always being
quite beautiful boy
is the one of the best places in the
world to start today in I think we've
got the quietness of the bush as the
sunsets become through the chorus of
birds start up and also it's coming
sorry we hate that what as we come this
hill so I'm fortunate that we can't
really broadcast to well coming down
this hill because there is some great
scenery and some great views that we can
get from up here and it's also good just
to scope here as well when we are coming
down we've got a big distant view so
although there is quite a bit of long
grass through here you definitely see
things from afar I have spotted lions up
here on a couple of times so it's been
it can be handy
[Music]
absolutely a gorgeous day draft girl is
saying it's like a rollercoaster coming
down it it is a little bit it's a fun
Hill it is a fun Hill to come down and
get a little bit bumpy but once you come
down here a hundred times you find it
get used to it I wouldn't have been down
here a hundred times maybe 50 or 60
times but still enough enough to start
to get used to well the little cracks
and crevices are all the bits they're
gonna wreck the car so not much
happening down here there's it's a
giraffe off in the distance
ngn it is looking great the light is
really making all of the greens stick
out this afternoon so everything is
looking very green and very fresh I wish
I could say that everything was well I
mean everything is green and fresh but
there could be definitely a lot more
water around at the moment
the rivers unfortunately are looking
pretty dry whoop the yeah there's just
not as much water it's great for for the
places where the roads can get quite
muddy and quite treacherous it
definitely prevents marshmallowy
as I so famously do but yeah still it
would be nice to have it be the rain
oriented and also just being out here
when there is a storm having only our
tents between us and the brains and the
storms it's really quite beautiful it is
it is so so nice to still be safe and
protected from it but you know be in it
to feel like you're deep in it it's it's
really quite relaxing I find so I do
like my evening rains and makes it
finding animals a little bit harder but
one animal that is very very easy to
find is this one right here because well
look at the size of him
the immerser giraffe that has undergoes
a gestation period of 15 months and not
22 months just to clarify that for a
second time it is the elephant at that
it does it 22 months now I can tell this
is a male straight off the bat because
of the bald ossicones they do use their
heads and their necks for fighting and
it removes the removes the hair from the
ossicones
obviously you can imagine repetitively
hitting your head against another not
quite tall enough I never thought I'd
see the day where a giraffe is not tall
enough some of the old acacia species at
that that's the giraffe a feed on
actually have communication amongst one
another so if they are eaten the leaves
are eaten they will start to produce I
believe it's a cyanide compound that not
only tastes unpleasant towards the
giraffe itself but we'll send a chemical
message downwind to other trees and so
they will up the production of this
compound as well and then well the
giraffe can't either so they will have
to eat downwind I mean sorry upwind I'm
just going to reverse of it so we don't
lose a picture here
and so yeah it's really interesting I've
actually been reading a little bit of a
book called the secret life of trees
going on about their communication and
how they actually well they have more
forms of communication than we know
their roots in some forest areas the
roots of trees can actually donate
nutrients to trees that have been broken
down or are dying somehow and actually
help to bring them back to life so
there's actually communal care in some
untouched tree ecosystem or not
untouched but less spoiled and they can
also communicate through sending pulses
or some sort of impulse through fungus
in the soil which is just unreal
absolutely unreal and they even have
their own sort of nerve impulse I think
it goes with about a third of an inch
per second so very slowly but there is
some sort of impulse there yet cool
stuff there's about a three giraffe that
I can see right here very nice against
the ole ole ole ole escarpment
keV can giraffe swim well I've never
actually seen a giraffe swim and I
wouldn't imagine if they could they
would be able to do it very well but I
don't think giraffe tend to stay away
from more than unless they are drinking
it yeah it's hard to picture a giraffe
swimming but I'm sure that they could
I've done a hundred percent sure that
they probably have the ability to swim
all mammals do but I just don't think
that they do it that much as I said I've
never seen it but I am sure that they
can do it they wouldn't have to worry
about getting any water in their nose or
mouth because it would be well above the
water what a beautiful beautiful
afternoon scene this is the little Scout
Minh is breathtaking it's just dotted
with trees places saying it looks like
an adult drop with a toy a giraffe
that's the younger one that does look a
little bit like a plush toy I wouldn't
actually mind it to having a girafft
sized well a giraffe bears a graph teddy
bear a giraffe plush toy I think that
would be the right way to say it that
size it would be awesome you could use
it as a chair he said there's a beanbag
or beanbag giraffe beanbag an elephant
beanbag that would be even better a real
true scale elephant beanbag
I would definitely chuck one or two of
those about the camp be very cool
actually just even a lion anything that
you could just lay down on and pretend
it is the actual animal yeah yeah we
could chuck it on the back of the
vehicle Emma great idea great idea from
MZ in FC all right well you gonna
continue on my bumble now leave it is
giraffe to you do what's those giraffe
who do it and not be tall enough to get
the leaves from the trees that was quite
humorous not really irony but let me
know what you would call it
nature girl I definitely prefer the Mara
to Juma for a number of reasons I the
area Mara is a lot bigger so we get to
experience a lot more out here and
Traverse more areas and get a well I'm
not sure about diversity but we just get
more sightings out here in the Mara
because of how open and large it is and
there's also just so many elephants here
which is great you can't really go
anywhere without seeing elephants and
also camp as well in Zuma we're quite
restricted as to where we can go in camp
but because we're right up on the
escarpment out there we have a bit more
freedom as to where we can go in terms
of moving about and the altitude here
definitely contributes to Fitness I am
finding I have to put in little effort
to get more rewards with fitness goals
which is absolutely great and the people
here are really nice and so I just yeah
I feel really really at home here it's
very easy to to clear the minds and just
you know really focus on nothing but
nature and and just be amongst nature
all the time so while we do get to do
that in Zuma I just feel like I can do
that at a greater degree out here don't
get me wrong I love tumour I love being
able to see the leopards all the time
and I love all the people there of
course but just something about the Mara
really really appeals to me
and yeah I think it's also because we
can really follow the Lions
I love the Lions in Juma their
territories kind of go through Juma but
they are not all in Toomer whereas here
we have so many different lion
territories in the area that we can
actually Traverse and so it's a lot
easier to follow on their stories and -
yeah really interact with them and then
get to know what they are doing at all
times of their life not just when they
are passing through and I mean the
scenery out here if jhummer is pretty
flat and so there's not many elevations
our areas of elevation where you can
look out across very nice so there's
also that advantage here in the morrow
of having so many different levels of
elevation sweets history it is great it
is very very great I am thoroughly
thoroughly enjoying myself out here in
the Maasai Mara
it's yeah it's kind of become my
stomping grounds a little bit I think
towards me and Lauren oh yeah that's a
great idea I think I might ask everyone
what do you like better from a viewer
point of view do you prefer the morrow
do you prefer Juma use the hashtag
Safari live or you can comment in the
YouTube chat stream let me know would be
interested to hear all of your thoughts
obviously you guys don't live in dream
or live in the Mara and so it would be
cool to see an outsider's perspective
all right well I'll let you all sit on
that one for a Louisville I'm sure
there'll be plenty of answers coming in
in the meantime let's ask Cory what he
thinks does he prefer to dreamer or the
Mara not true boredom are into Anna
petit
I love Juba I'm not saying Maura is not
beautiful but this is what makes me to
love tumour to see these youngsters what
happened is we left the western side
because we didn't see any fresh tracks
moving in and out of the reserve so we
said let's go and check the hyena den
and we are here hello and what I love
about Juma is the number of leopards you
can find yeah and then it's difficult in
the Mara to see leopards you have to be
lucky to see one oh I'm trying to look
at at the heap day
because if it has some white fur then
and it will be plunk I didn't see any I
think this is one of pretties cups
no g-dragon ooh it is it is this plunk
or not I'm not sure I'm trying to figure
out because plunk is he he has this
white fail on its own on his hip I can
say yeah let me move forward a little
bit and see I feel good here this hyena
looks lost because it's alone here
understand what happened was we saw one
moving away from the den side and then I
can't see any adults around only this
one
and I'm pretty sure if is this not plunk
its its prettiest Cubs Ted what else do
I use to identify hyenas spots markings
from the previous injuries I mean they
don't look the same even if you look at
their faces once you get used to them
you can tell this face belongs to whom
this face belongs to whom and you think
this hyena saw like cats like for
example leopards they look the same they
don't look at the same
so as I've said if it is not plunk mmm
some of the viewers I think this is
pretty scrubs that's what I thought also
because I didn't see any anything like
clunk because we can tell applaud for
Mattie stain that that one is plunk and
pretty is uh is one of the females
defined here this is a human ten then
it's one of the low ranking females and
plunk the one we are talking about it's
the son of cocky is the matriarch
of this trend I can see they've grown up
because Cubs they go in the ten if
they're adults are not around the ten so
it simply means this one it's it's it's
getting big and and and and and stronger
and full of energy you can see he's
starting to have a big heart now he's
not afraid of being alone outside of the
tent
I wonder if it's safe around here for
such a young hyena so while I'm I'm
still figuring out what's happening with
this lonely hyena let's go to pet in the
mirror I honestly wasn't expecting that
I thought because of his wild dog
sighting out here he would have said
tomorrow but each to their own
collie is a true South African bush
wanderer he yeah I suppose that does
soothing more down that way very trained
in that area so I am still just bubbling
about still looking at to find anything
as I said it's quite hot ah Juma is
winning on Twitter as well that's very
interesting very interesting indeed I
think maybe perhaps our leopard
characters might have a little bit to do
with that what about you Emma
I mean FC what do you prefer I know that
you've been that to both what one would
you prefer
[Laughter]
she's saying we all know because of the
chapatis that probably the Mara and yes
I wholeheartedly agree that your parties
out here are to die for
no matter who you comes here I can
guarantee once they leave they are going
to be a shoe party lover it is just a
given Joelle a chef just knows how to
make a mean mean atcha party yeah
perhaps there is something going on in
this area because there is five vehicles
around to know for vehicles around me
right now they are all a mobile though
which is odd but I know six seven well
the vehicles everywhere but every all of
them are moving so I'm not sure whether
there is something here or whether
everyone's just decided to search this
area today generally if there's a lot of
vehicles parked within a close distance
of one another you could assume that
there is a good sighting there and
they're looking at something but to have
them all moving about in such a small
area is yeah
there has been word of something
happening in this area today I haven't
heard anything personally
so seems like there's a bit of a war
starting between who likes who better
Juma vs. Mara well I think the only
really the only reason the only way to
really persuade something is to give
some reasoning so as well as saying
where I would also like to hear what why
you like either of the two locations and
then we can make a better decision based
on that
what has brought everyone down here at
them over hats it's usually rhinos or
the river pride where I am right now
it's generally at those two other things
that bring up people about
this way anyway this way so not just
brings people out here
that's very cool so we're getting some
feedback from the reasoning why and
people are saying that they love the
scenery of the morrow but they love that
the personal characters and everything
in juma that makes sense that makes
sense I can I can agree with that most
definitely I suppose that's the
difference between the density of
animals that we have here in the density
we have in here music Tumen tumor haha
faith disagrees and he's saying what
about waffles yes it very true what
about waffles
stopped here for a roadside le Christine
is confused as to what at your party is
well if I had to describe it it's kind
of like a big Brady pancake that just
goes well with absolutely everything
kind of like what you would wrap a
silver Lackey or a kebab up in but more
I know it's got the kind of doughy
Dahlia texture but hold your horses
everybody because there is actually a
video coming out soon and that we will
put out there that will actually show a
little bit more insight into the
chapatis and why they are such a hit out
here in the Mara I don't know where the
rest of the herd this one is it must
just be a male roaming about it doesn't
look very big probably about half not
even half the size of some of the bigger
elephants out here probably it's still a
bit of a youngster know the youngster
youngster but bit younger than some of
the bigger bulls we get out here
okay well there's not much that it gets
it bigger than the African elephant
except what Ollie has no that's a joke
it's definitely not
you look what I found Sydney's favorite
this guy's on on a mission so remember
this is a down rolling pitot and you
rolls this tank for several purposes one
is to is to is to attract the female and
the other one is to feed on this tongue
then attracting a female female will see
the size of the town and then if the
female is uh if the female is is that is
fine again
just pick up take your whole Tiki hold
and then another generation starts so
I'm not trying to be around it because
it's on a mission is going into the
thicket day in in the process so let's
hope we'll see the future generation of
this dung beetles well I left the high
unit end because I've realized that
there's there's no adult day only that
youngster so at you know one wanted to
like to disturb him yeah if I can put it
that way because if the sometimes these
youngsters they get to be confused about
these cars because they're still young
can say more vulnerable
so if there was an adult day I would
have been there for a long time
oh we have a good we have cooties they
get them David
I have the coolest thing
[Music]
ah we can get these cooties moving into
the thicket and they can well
camouflaged maybe we'll find them on the
other side because we are moving towards
the same direction
oh here's another one they're on the
road we have keep going little bit let
me see what I'll get you a nice view
here yeah mmm hey kid yeah ah good it's
a female
they'll have horns and it's easily
recognized by the stripes on its body
and the height and this big years oh
here's a birthday on top has an ox
pecker
let's see whether I can sneak forward Oh
Frank do you oxpeckers feeds and Farrow
answer there let me just move forward
because I can't get these kudos let's
please be still please please please
don't move please please don't
can see it's browsing
and the kudos are so interesting because
they can feed on these thorny thorny
trees but they will just feel like
there's there's no thorns in those trees
just like the plant they are feeding on
right now it's a play black monkey thorn
or plant monkey orange it has these
vicious spines but kudi doesn't have any
problem to eat the leaves in this tree
this is a black monkey orange plant
so while I'm pressing forward
hopefully I'll find something with
rosettes but for now let's go to Tristan
who's also enjoying being in the wild
well our afternoon in June has been
fairly spectacular and all of you might
be wondering why would it be spectacular
and why have you not seen us for so long
well the reason is is because we can't
show you what we were watching for as
long as we were but we basically were
long watching a massive territorial
fight between two rhinos which is still
going on some way in the vastness of the
kruger national park and it's quite
something to be in the presence of these
massive animals when they fight one
another they we're having a full go at
one another at one point and it's just
incredible to be able to watch it and to
kind of see what was going on so you're
just having a little look at that and
Seb was trying to just get some shots
for slo-moes and things like that just
to kind of see how it all works
basically and can kind of study it at a
later stage I suppose but that's what
we've been doing which has been
absolutely amazing now part of me is
obviously astounded at the amount of
strength and sheer size of these animals
when they fight with one another it
really is quite something the other part
of me is incredibly sad and you might
ask why I'm pretty sure most of you are
actually asking why the reason why I'm
incredibly sad is because we are
basically we obviously drive around here
and we don't show them at all for
obvious reasons which we've been through
quite a lot but it makes me very sad
that we can't educate and show people
just how incredible these rhinos are
sometimes you know I think I understand
the whole process behind it and I get
why we do it but part of me just feels
like we're almost doing them a bit of a
disservice by not showing them sometimes
and especially when they do things like
what they're doing now because it is
absolutely fascinating to watch these
two animals go about their business it
was almost like watching a ballet if I
can say that hey Seb yeah so it was like
this ballet where they would be these
steps back and forth and it's like this
and dust and light and all these kind of
things and it's it's was like they a
performance that was being put on in
many ways and and the fact that we can't
show that because of certain greedy
people in this world really frustrates
me and it makes me incredibly angry that
we're in this place in this world where
we have these kind of things and these
limitations to you know to what we can
do because of this sort of minority that
ends up affecting everybody else and so
part of me gets very very very very
angry about the fact that we can't show
you guys these things and that like I
say I get the point behind it's and I
understand it and I you know part of me
maybe he's not 100% sure if it really is
the right way but obviously there's an
issue and it's just the fact that
there's an issue to start with is what
really frustrates me and and you know I
wish we didn't have that problem because
it would be so nice to show you guys
just how amazing these animals really
are and to show you an incredibly rare
sighting the fighting and territorial
disputes that take place between males
are not common at all and so to give you
an idea how long you been in the bush
now so all in all eight years Sebastian
and we spend a lot of time on the
vehicles as young you all know and that
is the first time ever that Seb has seen
rhinos actually fight with one another
and actually you really kind of have a
go at each other it's my only my third
time in as being a full-time guide in
life to see it and so it gives you an
idea of how incredibly rare it is to
witness two males going off to one
another and really having a huge fight
and like I say the fact that we can't
actually show that anyone really kind of
I don't know it makes me irritable and
makes my blood boil that is
first minority that has ruined it for
everybody else in some respects but
anyway it was amazing to watch and
hopefully the two boys cichlid without
hurting each other they were both got a
few little kind of surface scratches and
so but a few scratches on their faces
nothing too major there's not like these
blood coming out of either one of them
at this stage and they they kind of just
like I say doing this amazing dance
basically where these steps forward and
back and forward and back and eventually
they all get tired and one will move off
and they'll split but it's the effects
of basically dry season right now so why
they fighting is because we're starting
to get drier the dry season is starting
to take effect and so mud wallows are
far less and so attraction to water is
one two is I'm 99.9% sure that there is
a female in heat walking around there
was a huge fight between rhinos and a
few weeks ago very close to where Seb
and I stay and it looked from the tracks
like a female and a male that it's kind
of had a bit of a go at each other which
is quite common if there's a female in
Easter's and so I think maybe there's a
female interest which has brought both
of these equally sized bulls and it was
amazing to see because the two of them
at one point we had them side on in
front of us and they are exactly the
same shoulder height and bulk wise
exactly the same width but they're
whitener has got a slightly longer horn
and when I say slightly longer and it's
just a little bit longer so they really
evenly matched and that's why I think
they're being so delicate about this
process at the stage and pretty sure
they trying not to kind of want or one
doesn't want to actually die or kill
itself by being too close so it's this
kind of dramatic dance that takes place
with dust and lights and animals which
is amazing so James the black rhino is
not as much I think as the white rhinos
but they do have it and it's quite a
real revelation a few years ago when
they realize how social black rhinos can
actually be I mean etosha there's a pan
there that's at nights they proceeded up
a camera and these rhinos came in and it
was incredible to see that they were
actually a lot more sociable than what
we think and so I think you know it
depends also where they occur if
a lot of resources and those kind of
things then generally they'll probably
be a little bit more kind of tolerant
but very very very interesting kind of
to see that the the black rounders seem
to be in some ways a little bit more
tolerant of one another except I think
if there's a female in Easter so I think
if females and eustress tends to be the
tipping point for both black and white
and that will make both of them quite
grumpy with one another but it's an
amazing thing to see animals of that
size fighting it's like a hippo fight or
a elephant fight which actually reminds
me funnily enough talking about elephant
fights I don't know if everybody
remembers a few weeks ago I saw an
elephant that I said had lots of blood
coming down from the side of its ear and
we didn't really get a good view of it
they kind of just rush past as two bulls
chasing one another and it actually
turns out that that bull elephant was
the elephant that was found on before
Zook that died and the Tusk went through
his ear and through the back of his leg
and actually punctured and got infected
and huge caused a huge infection in both
his ear and his side and he was found to
be dead on that side of the world so
it's it's a shame that he died but
there's at least an update so I know a
lot of you were asking me if I had heard
anything about that a li we didn't get a
good enough you to see what was going on
but I just remember seeing that blood
and it's obviously turns out that it
must have been him because the the
wounds match exactly the wounds that I
saw on that elephants and the guys that
went and saw it on before so told me
exactly what they saw and it was pretty
much the same thing to be honest so yeah
not very nice twin ring these big
animals fights right now I'm not sure
where we're gonna hit from here I'm just
kind of thinking of whether I'm gonna
find la mort anyhoo be richens somewhere
here so I'm just having a kind of look
at all the trees and checking tracks
that's why are we going quite slow good
well we're gonna carry on we gonna see
if we can find something that we can
actually show you and in the meantime
though let's send you back across to
Holly who's investigating or tolls
yes good luck Tristan with your leopard
I'm also searching for a leopard I'm not
lucky yet
all right spirits aquatic species of
bird this is called a saddle bail stock
because of its big it's more like the
shape of a saddle oh it's drinking water
they and you know you can you realize
that it's working in water that simply
means it's disturbing he's trying to
disturb the the prey like the frogs the
fish crustaceans and the aquatic insects
oh nice one day I wonder how many liters
or amount of water does it drink with
that big oh yes the light is beautiful
and you can simply tell the male and a
female just by looking at the base of
the peak day the female doesn't have her
wattles
and then the male have Oh bottles cans
you can see there we can spot the yellow
bottles lay the hanging in this is a
male and the male has duck eyes the
female has a yellowish eyes oh what a
nice looking peak Oh disagreeing with me
and you also have our favorite bread of
all time a blacksmith Lapwing
and there are a lot of stocks we find in
this place but we this one we normally
see them so enjoying the peace around
this water hole let's go to the Mara and
see what's pet it's doing with the
Highness well some high in the river and
I've been to this den before it is that
I believe that the ole ole ole ole clan
this is a part of their den here we can
see one of the Cubs here last time I see
there were two cubs and two adults and
one of the adults was heavily pregnant
they are at the moment there is only one
adult and one Carbet present and the
pregnant one is not around where she is
what she is doing and hopefully well we
have some very fresh cubs to come and
look out here soon as well I remember
seeing this one the last time starting
to get that nice a spotty coach coming
through very nicely now
very very fluffy looking very soft and
cute at the moment this one here and
quite timid as well it was a little bit
hesitant to come out when we first
approached but after seeing that we were
nothing into worried about it's very
much relaxed and yeah they both seemed
to be a very much relaxed near oh sweet
eyes on hyena Cubs the best ieveis in
general had just the best oh this one is
a little bit skittish
[Music]
hyena Cubs are born very precocious
yeah well demonstrating right there that
they love biting things and they are
born actually we'll all of their teeth
erupted and well very strong both jaws
already so they come out biting in
sniffing and training up those jaws see
them eating a whole range of things I've
heard of people that well having so much
domesticated hyenas but have looked
after them that they just absolutely
destroy everything they always always
are tearing things up in their young age
way way worse than any dog I have heard
melting melting melting and this has
actually given me a little bit of
inspiration as well so I haven't really
had any I haven't really had any any
plans for this Drive but I think what I
might do is go and see if I can find to
the north clan I did run into them the
other day and I know that Lauren and the
hyena research team would both be very
interested to see whether this is a
permanent dinner or not or whether they
were just passing through so I'm gonna
go back up that way and check if they
are in fact it's still there or not so
yeah thanks for the thanks for the
inspiration that little hyena paula was
saying that she loves the way he has the
look and peeks around so though I it was
very very cute when I first showed up
and just his little head or he or she
actually I shouldn't say this is a he
because I don't know the sexes but just
kept poking little head out having a
look around and hello
very very sweet stuff alright alright
let's keep moving on go ahead up and see
if I can relocate the north Clancy they
are still hanging it about that would be
quite cool if they were you know a spot
way to say oh sorry lil one I didn't
mean to startle you
everyone's liking my plans of going for
the North Klan well good it makes it a
lot easier to execute a plan when all of
you are on board and with me strength in
numbers team
so yeah I mean we're not overly far away
so probably about a 15 minute drive
maybe 20 minutes
Jim Jim is asking fly for fur hyena or
lion cubs oh that is a real tough one
that is actually quite tough because
hyena Cubs I mean when the both in play
it's just so sweet but hyena Cubs to
have a bit more of the clumsiness to
them or maybe a bit more of a curiosity
I find that often leads them in - very
funny situations and then I find the
lion cubs have a bit more kind of I
don't know what you would call a bit
more prowess a bit more playfulness and
a bit more I don't know there's a seems
to be a little bit more coordination
involved with what the lion cubs do but
in terms of which one I like better it
is really hard to say I mean between
them baby elephants as well I mean it is
hard to pick it is hard to pick always
been a lover of babies and even human
babies when I was a teenager and a young
kid I was always looking after my
younger cousins
so let's just go to the conclusion that
young animals are cute I mean that
applies that to most most animals that
we get
we've got settles up
come through some roadside alleys
looking very mud-covered I'm glad
they're keeping cool everyone's agreeing
saying it's a good choice is just to
neutralize the playing field just to
generalize it looks like we have a
little roadblock up ahead
yes that was my elephant boys now that
was just my greeting voice I have a
strange greeting voice I like to greet
the animals that when I come out here
hey hey so this one is a little bit
right into by me so I'm just gonna stop
the car and wait till he relaxes and
moves a bond looks pretty young probably
maybe about five maybe a little bit
older no yeah no older ones in sight
there was a couple back there that we
saw this one just chillin out to by
itself at the moment going back to
eating now obviously a bit more
comfortable so which means I can move on
it's just going to prove what I was
saying earlier about however I love that
there is always elephants around in the
Mara it's probably the most frequent
thing that I am a road blocked by and I
am never ever ever frustrated no matter
how much of a hurry I am in to get
somewhere I can always stop for an alley
or a roadblock
rightio I'm going to continue on follow
up and see if I can find the North Klan
let's go back down to you Antoine it
into are not Paulie
at least we have found the beautiful
landscape in tomorrow the time where was
our day it was so easy sometimes to to
to look for big cats like for example in
line you just have to stop and then go
and stand on top you up on it
and look at the cars there if you see
two three cars and one sighting that's
where you must go might be a leopard or
a lion so here we have to track we have
to look ha
after such and such and such and such
Jumma can be difficult sometimes during
the season
so I'm going back to the western area
there's this thing that's busy telling
me that I must go and then check check
that jihad to get chem else inhuman no
no we don't get them we we get something
like that I normally think it looks like
camels like kudu the one we just saw
earlier on
mm tracks nothing can only see a hyena
track Impala tracks
this is my favorite tree over here David
because we find a lot of periods
industry but now nothing they left us
this place
that's an OP thorn tree
it has the knobs all over its body
David wants to know do sunbirds prefer
certain trees how can I put this
no no but when it comes to breeding or
nesting I think there will they will go
to a certain place where there's trees
but there are nest in trees they they
nest in in oh yeah sorry I'm talking
about the BET's the sand pits they
profess trees that full of thorns or
spines because they they have this Cup
nest so that they need they can't
protect themselves from predators so
what they do is they make it difficult
for a predator to to invade the nest so
they will they will go for this
complicated tree which has thorns or
spines they do prefer certain trees to
nest but to sit and then and make calls
and attract females they can go for any
tree
so I nearly confused myself with the
BET's and in the sandwich
so I'm on my way searching for a rosette
to the cat which is a leopard let's go
to petit Namara who's also on its way to
the hyenas all right well I hope we both
find what we are looking for man collie
I hope we can both catch up with well
probably two of our most famous clans
here on this Safari live the North clan
and the juma clan
yeah mr. drew McLean definitely
definitely do miss Corky and a little
clunk especially because when I first
started at Juma was just as plunk was
starting to come into the world and
starting to grow and so we pretty much
got to see him and grow right through to
the younger male that he is and they are
still so definitely a young cub but
starting to come into his own as a hyena
and I am a little bit sad but I'm not
there to see it but then again also you
have all of this out here and now I've
finally seen a leopard our ear I don't
have to miss the leopards of Juma so
much now
Wild Eyes that's a tricky one to answer
so I was emotionally involved in with
marine creatures but not in the same way
out here out here or non land we can
spend a lot of time with characters we
know are the same so I'll use lions for
an example here we say the only no pride
I'd know who the away no pride is I can
go and find them I can spend a lot of
time with them and follow their story
with an intimate detail this doesn't
tend to happen so much I'm the war that
we don't have the pleasures of doing a
lot of the things that we do underwater
on land I'm sorry other way around on
land as in water so that kind of limits
the emotional interaction that we can
have so I have seen some very sad stuff
in the ocean but I haven't intimately
known that the creatures that it has
happened to because it is just so much
harder to follow the stories but also
some absolutely breathtaking moments I
mean octopus fighting is one of the most
crazy things I've seen in my life it is
like they are changing not only changing
shape in front of your eyes but changing
color in front of your eyes it's like
watching true aliens fight absolutely
incredible stuff and just spending time
in a Zen moment with some leafy sea
dragons down in South Australia these
see these leafy sea dragons you picture
a bigger sea horse with long kind of
seaweeds of looking appendages coming
off that helps them camouflage into the
kelp and the brown algae that we get
down there so they are very slow-moving
because of that camouflage they kind of
just drift in the water so once you find
one you can spend your entire dive with
them and
I don't know they're just such a unique
creature that actually Dave Burton Barr
is favorite animal or at least favorite
marine creature and I can definitely see
why
and so that's an emotional interaction
but it's not it's not like be personal
it's not as personal I suppose is the
one we get out here I'm sure if you
spent enough time down there you may get
to start to know these leafy sea dragons
but at the end of the day all they do is
just kind of drift around and eat my sad
shrimp but once it comes to breathing
then things really starts getting
interesting because like with sea dragon
I mean seahorses the males who hold the
eggs well they'll be after they have
been fertilized so yeah it's less
personal with the ocean but still very
emotional good and bad emotions
Hey I mean in some ways it's relatively
easy to draw comparisons between water
and land but sometimes it's quite it
difficult a lower more say she loves all
of those creatures yes well she did get
to know a lot of our ocean creatures
during dive live I do remember our Lara
more asking many a questions and being
involved with all of the diets
unfortunately though we were very far
away from Australia so I could have a
show on leafy sea dragon we could show
some very cool stuff we've never got an
octopus oh there's one time that we got
in the octopus while we were in a live
broadcast by the time the government had
come over the octopus was gone it was
one of those days where the gremlins
just got in the way at the worst of time
and so that was a bit of a
disappointment but we did find some very
very cool stuff on our dives out there
in the Caymans
so right now just kind of edging a bit
of a bend in the river and then that
takes it takes us left to where the plan
was sewing well it depends it depends
where I decide to go so there'll be okay
so this I don't always follow this
process but this just to generalize
things should help so firstly if I have
a known update or a known sighting that
I'm interested in and would like to show
you off then I will go straight to that
area and look around there but a lot of
the days there just isn't the updates
and we don't know what's going on and so
if that's the case I'll decide on an
animal I would like to look for a lot of
the time in his lines because I am
following the prides quite closely at
the moment and so I would go to their
known territories or perhaps if it's
something like a leopard or a rhino or
go to their known habitats and so it can
all depend and I mean a lot of the time
it is just what I feel like doing or
what I feel like saying and
Dandan mongers are moving through very
quickly here we might get two right
there so we've got some banded mongoose
here and so yeah sorry I mean it can
really vary but yeah signs I mean
there's also days like today where I
just kind of decided I would I would let
the chips fall where they may and you
know sometimes when that happens you do
end up picking up on something and that
can completely change the direction but
sometimes you just keep bumbling about
and trying to enjoy it this is the
banded mongoose one of the more social
species of the Mongoose one that we see
quite a bit out here in the Mara
definitely the one I've seen the most
I've only seen one white tails of
Mongoose and apart from that that is all
but the banded mongoose are ones we see
quite a bit carnivorous as well these
little carnivores they are in the order
Carnivora pestered a family they have
all disappeared near always love a good
banded mongoose sighting they're usually
pretty brief as they are always on the
move but I was lucky enough the other
day to come across at some that were all
around a little piece of carrion I
didn't know exactly what's wrong but
they had a piece of meat that they were
sharing amongst them one at a time saw
that so that was very cool to watch very
cool indeed
like Oh same just coming up and then
left and then that takes me towards
Sarina Lodge Brennan yes they are
related the honey badger
and the Mongoose they're not closely
closely related but they both are these
carnivorous mammals everyone's okay yep
there's a beautiful no I've said a few
times now but this afternoon likewise
it's just absolutely gorgeous absolutely
gorgeous
love this place I really really love
this place
so nice so nice indeed that I'm actually
just going to pull over here so we can
see across the landscape well I'll sit
here for a while and enjoy this okay
well okay let's have a quick look across
here just so you can all enjoy the scene
that I am gazing upon right now and see
topi zebra Impala and buffalo dotted all
across the landscape and that light is
just phenomenal slight slight slight
mist over the escarpment really really
bringing everything it together so
picturesque isn't it to die for all
right well it's not just a sunset here
down in jhummer the sun is starting to
plummet as well and mr. Morley is
driving right into it so let's go yet
see what are you seeing apart from the
sunset oh I think my socks are chasing
away these animals I think I'm cool I'm
going to take them off so for now let's
just listen and maybe we'll be lucky to
hear some few things that might sound
promising yes
you hit it
it has stopped it was squirrel allow me
yes
David let's go D it's just coming from
the boundary the southern boundary here
I hit a squirrel alarm again it's still
a la me
hopefully you'll find something because
it sounded not far from where we were at
and remember schools have this great
eyesight then that simply means they
might see something from fun and they
will get it they will Adam for that but
I can appreciate why is it
Nandi who want to know why school
sometimes are not reliable because they
can see from far and they can Alan for I
think that is very far from where they
are and it's looking and sometimes might
be a cat pair of gray what snake we take
it said closer look here what's
bothering you buddy
and I'm sure you can hear you can also
hear this scroll is angry and I kind of
call off their car because I I don't
really know what he's looking at
so while I'm I'm looking in these bushes
maybe I'll be lucky so for now let's go
to pet with the hyena and the zebra well
very interesting scenes here so there's
just this one hyena amongst this herd of
zebra and it's been giving chase through
all of the young zebra all of the young
calves that are moving through there's
heaps of zebra coming through and
there's just this one who I eat and it's
been sitting in the grass trying to hunt
a smaller zebra all of the younger ones
it's had that Trudeau's now it's had two
attempts just they've just been short
lives chases but it's a very strange
very very peculiar it's just a single
hyena doing this
not sure who this hyena is maybe one
from the North plant bug maker that is
crazy isn't it very very strange thing
to come across
I saw the hyena around the zebra yeah
I'm not really sure what's going to
happen here but let's take a bit of a
risk and open this up to an unscheduled
it's a bit of a hard one to make sense
of but yeah
welcome everybody to this special
unscheduled broadcast we are coming it
to you from the Masai Mara Game Reserve
here in Kenya my name is Patrick joining
me on the lens is Archie and you can
interact with us throughout this our
broadcast using either the hashtag
Safari live on the Twitter or the chat
the stream that you are using now we
have a strange situation here that I
just thought that I would share with
everyone so right here this hyena has
been lurking in the grass but to my
right and I'll just move a little bit of
reality to see better bear with me here
so just to my right here there is a big
herd of zebra now as they were moving it
through this hyena has had two attempts
at taking a fall taking a young zebra
and both times it was just a short-lived
to chase but definitely it was a chase
at them but it's just strange to see
only a single hyena hyena z' will
generally hunt in packs their brain is
developed to problem solve together and
I don't know maybe this one just felt
too ambitious felt lucky I was kind of
on the way up towards that area through
words the area where these hyenas are
seen this North clan of hyenas and yeah
it just came across yes Park maybe is
desperate for food
desperate times do call for desperate
measures and this one seems to be
getting very desperate so looks like the
zebra have picked up that there is
danger here and have moved around a bit
it is a huge herd this lion has just
kept coming and coming and coming I can
still see them off in the distance
we've already had about 60 move through
now so just
yeah he
Cinthia I'm not sure whether they are
the most intelligent predators but they
are definitely up there with the most
smart of the Predators so their
prefrontal cortex I believe it is the
part of the brain associated with
problem solving and working in a group
is very developed to that develop that
has developed of that of the primates of
some of the primate at least so they are
very very clever animals hyenas
but in this account this one wasn't
clever enough to get itself a meal it
seems like the zebra have it picked up
that is here Brenda I'm not sure whether
are you alone hiding it could take a
fall down it would be a pretty big
battle it would be a struggle Sparta
yeah I would think that it would have to
bring it down in a bit of a pack it
would be an interesting one to watch and
whoa this one is still looking at the
zebra but I just can't see any clan
mates or anyone else around
did seem to be trying the ambush
approach it was hiding in this long
grass here Karissa Nuria is injured
zebras that I've seen it seemed to be
targeting and be young and well it was
definitely targeting the young but none
of them had seemed to be badly injured
at all those ones were looking at the
hyena I think it's most definitely being
spotted
it was the odds were against it enough
to start with but now that they have all
noticed I don't think that we are going
to have anything happen here
unfortunately it was definitely worth a
try alright I'm just gonna move around a
little bit there are other cars coming
through
Marcy saying she loves watching them run
it is very cool it's quite dazzling in
fact there was a play on words say a
group of zebra isn't known as a dazzle
very fancy
all right well thank you all very much
for joining we're sorry that we didn't
get anything happened there but we will
most definitely stay around at the area
and if anything it should unfold you can
tune in along using the hashtag no not
using the hashtag just fight 5-million
safari live on youtube we hope to see
you all there thank you for joining
welcome back everyone oh that was quite
an interesting little siding wasn't that
very strange to see and well this line
of zebras is never-ending there is so
many starting in it to make it their way
through at the moment we can see all
along here just keeps going and going
and going so right after you guys came
to me was probably about twenty has
moved through so it's just the start of
the line but this is just I can't even
see the end of this line right now it is
very very cool
all of these zebras here on the grounds
but Paulie has it something a completely
different twelve doesn't well spends a
bit of time on the ground
yes look what we have found I will tell
you the updates of that squirrel but I
was take talking about this area on the
dwarf mongoose and a hornbill they are
just next to each other can see the
relationship it's it's great
who's that hunter so that the horn pill
will alum first if there's a there's a
predator or danger outside of the 10 and
then it will elect the two of Mongoose
about that situation crazy hey and if
you think about the 12 most pink are
divas oh we have a small migration here
we have our own migration yeah you get
that that they are going from Juma to
other the other reserve so they have to
cross let's see what's happening they're
still looking around before they cross
you know they're predators lurking
around so that's why they have to be
careful at all times before they cross
this boundary in the eastern western
part of the reserve so they're coming
from the east going to the west let's
see who will make it to the next
boundary
we have vehicle coming and it's going to
spoil the migration
Oh let me shift for this car because on
its back it's going to - it's going to
destroy our migration here he's doing
let's hope it's going to be the real
migration of - Valda pierced
been here in Toomer we don't have
migration like the Mara animals like
these ones they used to migrate from
east to west north to south but they had
to do that now because we have this
man-made water hole so they don't need
to migrate because there's abundant of
water and vegetation so that's why we
see them often in in one area or they
are migrating here they go here they go
you can see one at the back it knows
that the dangers are lurking around so
that's why it's looking left right left
right before it crosses the main road
here they go here they go the one has
crossed and the other one is going to
the thicket now who we have my crazy
humor migration that's awesome
so we didn't find anything after that
squirrel alarming because I think that's
we're all just alarming because it can
because that sometimes I think they just
alum for fun because we've searched and
look and locked
so while we searching and searching
still searching let's go to pet in the
Mara
look at this beautiful assessing in
front of me and I've just come back
because I just didn't want to leave this
sighting just yet the hyena is sitting
right here and still it just looking at
like what's going again
it's still you need the grass here you
can't see the moment but it's still
giving me zipper a hard time where is it
and we can tell where it is just because
there's a zebra will speed up
it is hyena definitely definitely
interested and definitely wanting
together are just not sure how it's
going to pull it off by it so especially
when there are so many zebras here so we
take a look from the front of the line
which is way down to my right here
that's not even the beginning where
we're looking right now is not even the
start and we are nowhere even near the
end of it so I just in between segments
they did a drive to just see how
extensive this herd of zebra was and it
took me about a minute to drive from one
end to the other and this was going
against them as well so they were moving
in my direction which made it even
quicker to pass them so that just gives
you an idea of just how many there are
out here right now so wonder how long
before they get followed by some Velda
beasts a bit of a way that the
wildebeest benefit from these areas that
the zebras will eat the longer grass
leaving the shorter and they're saying
this is a little bit more substantial
than the true builder beasts migration
that Corey has down in juvenile it'll
bit more just by bit I can see this fire
in the grass in front of me
oh look at that look at that and is a
heavenly sky
hmm okay so I've just received word from
mr. Hendrie about what he thinks is
happening with this hyena and he said
that hyena is fishing so pretty much
just trying to wean out a weak one so
you can get in there and get it and so
that seems to be at what this one is
doing trying to figure it out but I can
see now he's just here retreating next
through me at the moment just coming
through the grass here over to the other
side where there's more so we will stick
with this one just bear with me I'll
just turn the car around
helis nice coal that's what she calls a
zebra crossing
yes very very true the biggest a zebra
crossing in the world I think with a
little bit of planer thrown into the mix
okay so I can't see where the hyena is
right now but I can see a lot of running
oh it's right here right next to us
still peering yet
here I'm not sure whether the microphone
Pizza up but I could hear a very large
flatulence coming from one of those
obras they have very gassy animals quite
often scaring themselves by their own
pots I think is quite hilarious
I should leave that didn't come across
but I was walking around with a herd as
they brought up the escarpment and the
other day taking photos of them and my
conclusion of their lifestyle is that
they just pop and kick each other that's
all they seem to do is just fluctuate
and then kick one another in the process
as well so it didn't look too pleasant
it to be amongst that herd of there for
that day it's never ever ending line
animals just keeps coming and coming and
coming
I've never actually seen even an
attempted hyena hunt come to think of it
now so you will see a vehicle come into
shot in a second
Linda I think that zebra are the most
gaseous I definitely think although
elephants do fluctuate a lot I feel like
zebra Duryea even more fermentation
process contributes a lot of gases on
the job near just doesn't seem like it's
going to be able to even catch up with
one you know that high is very fit they
can run for a long time well one stop to
the face and was taunting they're just
saying hey come get me
they're just starting to reach the end
of this group of zebras now this is the
last little patch of them and they seem
to have wanted to take an ultimate
alternative route well I can see a
second hyena near so we have errington
alarming from the zebras just gonna
move around here one looks like it's we
might have a bit of separation here so
there's two waiting in ambush
I'll Larimore I would say that this is
multiple herds that have come together
oh I can see lots of hyenas so yeah
multiple has ever heard so okay there is
lots of hyenas down at where this herd
down here I'm just good to try and find
a road in there
this is turning out to be a very
interesting night
okay so there's a right that comes down
this is good
so I think I saw her about seats and
like annoyed
this was a good no plan plan wasn't it
guys very much so
and I wonder what's happened down here
all of this effort is still together so
I don't think there's been any strikes
launch can quiet it definitely does it
change everything adding it more hyenas
into the mix but this herd seems rather
calm now
very calming day
this is where all the allowing was
coming from I saw lots more hyenas down
here but maybe maybe one there's been a
kill may which I don't think has
happened or perhaps the zebra won in
defense because ya know hyena senior
oh I've got exciting for me then but
yeah they must offended bended them off
that's very confusing
well there's still those two that were
waiting over the other side so we'll see
if they are still doing something
haven't heard any calling it from the
hyenas to get others so we come and join
them in the hunt hopefully there are a
few more lurking around
Connie why won't the zebras just trample
them well I mean I suppose they could
but they were kind of walking it in a
single-file line
I think the hyenas are a bit too clever
to get trampled by them as well but I'm
sure if they all dare to group together
and make a fast movement at the hires it
would be very effective so I just don't
think that they would really know or use
that tactic
it's very strange though I've seen
hyenas around a number of prey items and
even though they are wary of them they
always seem to be able to get into close
distance without trying too hard to
really hide themselves or camouflaging
themselves I'm not sure what that is
about them but wouldn't the epic
together hyena hunt although I've had
have heard it can get pretty brutal to
watch as well just the way that they
actually kill the animals
[Music]
now I can't see the hyenas either I got
this one Brandon well they join with
will debates because they both want
nutrients from the grasses although a
zebra will attend it to eat oops sorry
zebra will tend to eat the different
grasses to the worldA beasts which kind
of clears them out and allows that err
access and so that is why you will see
the Zebras come through and then the
world beast do you know that is ever
coming in epic numbers that's all I mean
most the main focus of the migration is
the valda beasts but still the Zebras
come in very large numbers and well it
seems to be showing up right now there
has been a huge influx over the last
week of zebra well anyway speaking of
them all being in one area this is one
that they are not they have all cleared
out now and these hyenas that look
pretty relaxed this one right here looks
like it was intent on something but it's
just a vehicle off in the distance that
was looking at so I'm going to see if I
can find I'm not sure whether these are
actually north playing hyenas or not I'm
going to see if I can find the rest
anyway I'm not too far off where I was
when I found them in the potential den
site so that's why I'm thinking that
this was north by hyenas just because of
where we are right now
but we need oh the Lauren area and she
is good with her hyena ID is if I am not
so much in tumor in Zoomer I was
definitely getting there but out here my
focus has more being lions and hyenas so
well so no a lot of general stuff about
hyenas the the characters themselves I'm
not 100% familiar with at this point in
time but that is the beauty of the Mara
there is both time and space out here to
learn and observe
to get darkness descend upon us now it's
always an exciting time
dusk ERT it was a very interesting
interaction that one every one wasn't it
it was yeah definitely not what I
expected I the first time I saw a hyena
go into the grasses if it was going to
ambush the zebra I just thought no
surely not it's just going into the
grass arrest but then sure enough and
put up a chase and then again put up
another chase
all right well we've been going from
stripes to searching for spots and we
shall do that again let's check back in
on ollie and see how his search is
coming along this pet is enjoying
himself they in the Mara that's awesome
so we're still looking ha
you know I was talking to David before
we went live that in in this season like
this fake it I think I I must stop
saying my plans and to look for what in
what in what I just have to drive around
this area in and and find cat so maybe
kids will just show up when we're still
driving because it's so heartbreaking to
go to the west and then you don't find
tracks they ha and I really want to see
these kids but do you think David yeah
sometimes we we really need the wet
season but when it comes you get this we
get tickets
and just imagine we can see leopards in
these thickets what about the honey
pitcher
that's way smaller than a leopard once
said and once we said we will just see
it limbs of it and then it's gone
MTN you need wild ox and I had and
already that they are wall talk
somewhere I think Tristan if I'm not
mistaken is following up on that
hopefully you'll see while talks before
the end of the show yo turn up what the
Walters I remember being in the Martin
seeing the wall talks and I did one
mistake
I was excited more than the viewers that
was so magical but III didn't see that
I'm doing that because you know when you
are full of joy and let's go here let's
vestido we there's a pen they ahead of
us are about hundred meters from here
which is called chillip in let's go and
check it out
maybe we can see some powerful ooh
swallowing because we had a lot of fresh
tracks of buffalos yes all the other
guides were were jealous of my sighting
I'm not saying that it's a mine FC you
saying that I didn't say that and it was
ha
and I couldn't believe it that it's
happening because what happened was pet
saw the wall talks like and then then he
said Holly I think those are Walters but
they were from afar and then we were
just driving it just doing the trainee
tribe just driving around in and getting
to know the place and then we drove
drove drove forth then we saw that those
are our talks then what happened was we
were radioed James and we said James we
have the wall talks and James said only
you'll be live in few seconds and I was
I was in ready be it yeah you'd be life
because the first time and so far life
having the wall talks life in the Mara
and then I was like yes David keator
says I was full of joy
ah
there's a car coming I hate a fuss there
maybe we'll get some exciting news for
knows or some promising news from them
I have a question here that's coming
here but I have to grid before I untied
first
okay good thing suicide good any
promising news
thank you
thank you enjoy exciting news hey you
hear that I've asked the guy what's
happening any promising news and he said
yes his son has a new girlfriend hi Emma
please press in that question I just
miss slipped my mind
Oh
maybe have us in the wall toxin tumor
just a couple of times I've seen in the
invest tech breakaway pack and I've seen
this one I thought was an investor crack
away pack but James Richard confirmed
that it wasn't it was a-sayin spec or he
has cello pain nothing promising here
here's the pen David can you see the
pending yeah let's take a view and see
you maybe we'll find something feeding
Lee so are we still searching with no
luck but we won't give up let's go to
Tristan and see what his afternoon is
all about
and fortunate here we haven't had much
more lucky either don't worry well it's
been quiet other than basically what we
were talking about yes not really too
much
going on we still kind of just doing
circles around the sort of ingre alley
area but I see only is darn near chill a
pattern so I'm not sure where he's going
from there but now I'm trying to think
we are win ago because he's on that side
I was gonna go via that way we are you
yeah it's now just got to spot it so
he's a pill spotted outlet that's big
trees him right let's have a look let's
see if we can find it Seabrook scan with
the by knows they can be incredibly
difficult to spot sometimes but the nice
thing about the pill swatters is they
often don't sit right up against the
sort of bark of the tree they normally
sit on a little branch which makes them
often easier to spot in something like
little Scots ours or you know the white
face tiles there who you hide right up
against the block don't see where it is
definitely some way in that tree
from the audio and there's two of them
there's one on close to us and one
that's further away that's also calling
you just sit for a little bit hopefully
they'll call again now's the time of day
that they do call maybe even one will
fly for us which will be quite nice and
we'll be able to kind of see where
though or not where it is actually and
then give kind of a view but saves just
trying to scan around trying to see what
he can find
Sammy Jane you say there's a pearl alert
yes exactly
it's alerted us to its presence but not
enough that we can actually find it
unfortunately so I'm just trying to kind
of scan all the little branches and you
can see there's a lot of little hidey
places for an owl in this particular
tree not going to be very easy to spot
it
that's all often requires when spotting
Isles as you need a little bit of a
silhouette to a bit of movement just to
help you and then it's much easier but I
don't see any of that at all
and after our barn I mean our little bar
dolls yesterday which were super cool
for those of you that missed it we had
to borrow dolls next to each other
grooming they were really awesome so
maybe our pill spotters are trying to
outdo our bods
nope said I don't see anything
unfortunately and they still quiet so
let's carry on
Alyssa seems to be very little sound
coming from anything at the moment yes
it is quite a challenge Emma to be able
to outdo our little bard outlets from
yesterday nope I don't see anything all
right well so sorry a little bit more
dingy Naser much harder to make arts
what's the next sex like you see it
moving me oh it's going big black number
by the looks of things let's try and get
a little bit closer oh I've lost where
the grass is moving now yeah it was on
the road yeah lost it's now
I've lost it I don't know where it's
gone now unfortunately but it looked
black mamba yesterday Black Mamba has
this great typical kind of rays it comes
up and then it goes off into the grass
and it was the right kind of coloration
I just wanna go back and quickly just
check the track for it you see here was
the track Yarou
but I don't think I'm gonna be able to
actually get it's no it's going to be
too difficult to kind of get the right
angle on it unfortunately but it must be
living here because I just keep seeing a
track going back and forth over this
road I was hoping it would go up into
one of the trees but it's not
unfortunately well must have gone over
the road while we were just standing
there what was on the edge of the road
and we missed it unfortunately sorry
about that everybody it's very exciting
when we get to see snakes it's something
that we don't get to see all that often
get them every now and then kind of in
you know in termite mounds and trees and
various other things but it hasn't been
that many the season and certainly not
meaning that we've been able to put on
camera so it would have been really nice
to have had a little snakey to make an
appearance particularly a black mamba
and I find them fascinating snakes they
give you a bit of the kind of creeps
they give you those shivers when you see
them they've got a very evil looking eye
and this coffin shaped head which is
just kind of lends to the fact that it's
as dangerous kind of creature but I
really like them I think they they're
amazing animals and obviously highly
highly venomous and incredibly fast so
very very cool snake to actually watch
as long as it's not coming at you I
suppose quite glad it wasn't one of
those that tried to go up my pants the
other day that would have been very
awkward okay well we're going to carry
on looking we're gonna carry on seeing
what we can find in the meantime though
that sends you back across to pet who's
looking at ie nosov trying to find
hyenas
well we have come through the exact same
spot where I saw the North claimed the
other day and there is still members
here so we have a mother and their
youngster here and as I said I'm not
great with the IDS of the hyenas out
here so if anyone that does want to
chime in and help out please do use the
hash tag of Safari live on Twitter or
the youtuber chat stream to help out
with some of the identifications and
rise on cue we have it two more coming
in it to join all of the fun it's and
here it is then well not much fun going
on at the moment just some suckling but
here comes two more I did see one other
one as I was pulling up as well coming
it down towards the den so there's
definitely a lot of activity here oh
this one in a bit of a hurry there we go
oh what's going on seriously trying to
suckle is it I thought it was trying to
greet you know that a bit of a greeting
ceremony is to put the head in the
genitalia of the other but this one
seems to be competing with this cup here
a strange interaction this is we have
another cub coming in okay so that was
waffles
okay that was waffles down there on the
ground so the one that was nursing just
say most waffles which must mean it says
a Grenadier Grenadier grenadine which is
the cub there
I'm just gonna say quiet will you listen
to this grenadine and the other one is
ello down there very nice
that was a quite an odd little
interaction
seems to be just a lot of was sniffing
of one another at the moment
okay cool so it seems like this the
matriarchs Cubs one of them either chow
or there's a lob shower sorry but yes it
seems like that's the other one that has
it joined in and so that means that this
could be soups the matriarch who has
just taken over waffles at position of a
head dog big dog top dog no they're not
dogs at all it's just a figure of speech
so this one's trying to know who's
standing and we have boys trying to get
in there now actually chiki chiki is
that
[Music]
it has mmm crying out for some milk
she's gonna take the dominant position
seems like we have one there has taken
the dominant position and the other one
is their more submissive through the leg
position I've so often see in hyenas the
subordinate been forced between the legs
was a bit of a groom they're showing it
some love this is actually very pleasant
to watch these hyenas interact
Caltech saying waffles and the waffle is
most definitely they are waffling a
little bit right now aren't they so
where they are laying right now there's
a bit of a drain that leads under the
road I'm on right now and so that is
where I think the actual den part of
this this then is you know the actual
interior part where I am so if we like
right under me right now where I am
there's a bit of a excavation excavation
under the road and then on the other
side here is another drainage where I
did see Corky I mean waffles and a few
others the other day who also seemed to
have some carrion I couldn't see what
they had but I could definitely smell
that there was something down there that
was rotting it away and that they were
most likely feeding on and waffles
didn't look at too great that day either
she was looking very tired very flat and
a little bit ragged that seems to be in
a bit better condition this afternoon
and so we know that a few of you may
have been expecting a television
broadcast night for the SABC
unfortunately there was a soccer match
that is taking place tonight that is
taking up our slot so we will be
debuting this time next week so not this
week but next week so there's just been
a little bit of a delay because of the
soccer or the football I'm from
Australia so football to me is
Australian rules football but to call it
what you will that is why we are not
broadcasting a television show tonight
so that means that you can all enjoy an
extra hour of Drive with us here which
is fine but very excited for a
television to start next week I hope
everyone watching along is as well any
South Africans will be able to watch it
from their television on s ABC 3 so very
peaceful down here at the den at the
moment wasn't that just the definition
of Zen look at that almost dozing off
they're struggling to key for the eyes
open there how many if we got here now
one two three four five it seems like
there's about five here or resting
peacefully and whilst they do that let's
see which of the Antelope species
already has down in Juma
huh huh it's not promising it's really
not promising not tracks nor evidence of
a leopard around here
so we aren't black and white now we are
using a special light which is called an
infrared light so we don't want to
disturb the behavior of these animals
that's why we're not shining any
spotlight to them so you can see the the
eyes are reflecting who even was here
and also we have this special tool which
is called a FLIR camera oh and I hear
that can hear the baboon's alarming yes
you can see we have these amazing
looking impalas they're pink and
yellowish you can see the dark colors
blue and black and purple and it simply
means that specific area of spot is cool
or cooler and then the orange - pink
color you can see here it tells you how
warm it is and you can see the body
temperature it means is high so I just
had an an head in alum called Nana
so that's going to investigate that
because still have time to search around
let's go baby
the baboon's will be
showing us something and not forgetting
our spotlight but wounds are not ah
because yesterday in early today they
were in the camp so they are just
hanging around and they they have this
loud for that whoa whoa a vulnerable at
this time you know because the the
eyesight is not right during the night
so that's why they have to climb the
trees and go on top day so to say they
can have this vantage point and remember
Poppins they are really hate leopards
they are not friends
so I'll be driving to the north because
the sound came from the north
you can hear the bird according is
advertising their territory before the
night so while we are falling up oh
that's cool let's go to pet with the
highness
well I'm sure there is some segue here
into the fact that Tory Olli is heading
up north and I am with the north to
claim but my brain is not working enough
to think of one
so that was my Segway still very chilled
out here there's just been a few heads
prick up in the last minute or so this
one to the left here it seems to have
[Music]
mm-hmm that's definitely of course you
know this is a definitely caused some
suspicion here and some are moving off
now so I wonder if this is the ones that
we had hunting the line
[Music]
okay I also just heard zebra calling so
I think this is going to think I'm gonna
have to just yeah I'm gonna go back to
where I was before with those zebras
because I just heard zebras and hyenas
calling from
it sounded like around that area so I
think that's definitely worth
investigating given the events of the
afternoon and I saw at least one hyena
moving off in that direction from the
north clan just then and one also looked
interested so this might be worth
following up on so it's just a very
tight road here so it will probably take
me four or five turns to get around
take the car
all right well I want to see if we get
some action out here Tristan has well
something of a completely different
nature we do have action in the sky in
the form of a massive big thunder cloud
that has got lightning and it is
absolutely beautiful mesmerizing and
beautiful at the same time one because
it's not over our head which would have
been very unpleasant and two because
well the colors and of the lightning as
a total highlights that entire cloud is
absolutely wonderful and you can see
it's pretty constant lightning that's
coming through it's very late in the
season to be getting these major big
thunderstorms like that but some way is
getting a lot of rain through that
particular storm isn't that cool I
actually think it's a good time just to
sit and listen to kind of quietness
where is that storm even though there's
so much like being quite actually
hearing thunder so we're just gonna keep
quiet for a little bit while you watch
this
Oh mail lipids calling you yeah that's
him mail lipid is calling so we're gonna
try unfortunately we're gonna finish our
lightening and we're gonna race to try
see if we can get it I wonder if it's
not hook I'm worried it sounds like it's
coming from the western side so we're
gonna try and see if we can find a
cookie saber have you got your pants
bolted to the seats alright here we go
so nice when rusty is working well we
fixed rusty this morning well
Konrad and Marcela definitely did most
of the heavy lifting as they save it
yes it makes me go faster if I make a
noise it must be very snarky to me today
everybody she's being super she's saying
to me that I'm if I make noise then I go
faster and she's been giving me lots of
trouble but when I find a leopard she's
gonna be super happy all right here we
go say you see sometimes it's good to
sit and watch the lightening because it
allows you to be able to hear the lipid
that is sawing now where exactly it is
I'm not quite sure it sounds like maybe
Rebecca's Zoe's kind of Junction that's
roughly where I think now Emma's saying
she's taking a smokey page out of my
book at this stage
which I suppose is fair enough cuz I
give him a lots and lots of trouble
regularly we don't have much time do we
you know this is going to be a whirlwind
said what we've also going to try to do
is not actually squash state lipid as we
go around the corners and now Emma just
to add a little bit of pressure is just
giving me a friendly 14 minutes time
updates it's feel like I'm on a game
show being pressured as I go save you
still with us you're still here
excellent
right now Emma says to me that we're
gonna do the commercial break to build
the suspense and say hi race-off looking
for this leopard that sends you across
to pets who I think is investigating
there is alarm calling zebras go get
them at Tristan
good luck I hope that you can get us a
last-minute leopard so all the animals
are making it sounds for us to know and
I'm still following up on the direction
of that that hyena and zebra calls were
coming from nothing as of yet this era
have definitely clear the art from here
there's a large part of a parlor to my
left but they don't seem to be doing
anything except being in parlor
doing quite a good job at it - well done
it may mean palace in palace
take care own they they can definitely
sense fear so there's a lot of different
cues that animals can pick up on and yes
sometimes there's a there's a certain
sense that can be it picked up on a
certain chemical and so yes they can
sense fear I think it's probably a
better way to put it
not so much restricted to just through
smell but animals could definitely it
pick up on certain kinds of emotions if
you want to put it that way I'm
reluctant to say body language but for
example sharks great example is actually
sharks they can so the electric pulse of
the heartbeat if that's quickened up in
fear they can actually pick up on that
and that tells them that it is something
that that is scared of them and
therefore it must be pride and so that
is a good example of a way that animal
can its I almost can sense fear
and so that's why it's always really
important to try and stay calm around
animals because if they can sense that
you are unsettled well then they're
going to think that there's a reason
that you need to be unsettled and for a
predator it may be that they think that
you think well that you think that your
food
so that is why it is very very important
to be relaxed around animals even though
sometimes that they can scare the pants
off yet
well it's uh
pretty quiet around here not picking up
on anything well soon you continue to
search even and send you back up to
Ollie with more natural scenes wow what
a beautiful morning let me just keep
quiet and look at this view
David is viewing out it's really not
that see and I just didn't listen to all
the sounds of the wild
I can only hear one nocturnal bird which
is called a fiery necked Nigel and all
this horizon view with a dead tree
always spectacular
nighttime is the best one Kim has indeed
beautiful send you one with Twitter on
high stakes of my life
one feature her mine is well known magic
how do you feel about this African
sunset is always the best let's take the
last look before we we lose that light
from that horizon nice camera way David
yeah peaceful these are the things that
makes me to love being in the world
David what a nighttime scene yes it is
indeed this is one of the reasons why I
love spending time in these wild areas
spectacular David Laury no one retreated
speechless let me not say a word also
turn on the lights spotlight here number
one
let's go yeah some of the views summers
like Paul mesmerizing yes indeed some of
the views like not you can't find the
same like sports of use in in in
different areas more specially there's a
unique spot on on the east there will be
a unique spot on the west and so forth
and so those are the special moments I
love and especially when there are frogs
calling in the background rock rock rock
amazing so I'm still using my spotlight
it's nearly the end of the show but I
have had on the radio that there's an
alum call of a leopard
yeah Emma that one weight is very long
would you please say that slowly please
yeah I didn't get that let me stop and
listen to that do it just for a few
seconds what's that word again
James saying David is a camel wizard
with a dream let's move forward
David David is one of the best cameras
we have here I won't lie to you
and so oh oh I think we have an older in
oil - no in wool I think we have been
rused and we are talking about an oil to
see it there yes yes if you know we are
on IRA can see you can only see the
shape of this our that's why I says an
all because James uses the word all
I'm over the moon while I'm busy trying
to identify the school of mine let's go
to Tristan the leopard whisperer he has
something for you
success so he managed to find no kemuri
which is exactly why we thought it would
be obviously it's just his bottom at the
moment but it is definitely him he's
come from the sort of West and his
mobile kind of sat in India at the
moment so super cool that we managed to
find him Seb and I rush to where we
thought that was coming from and then we
sat there didn't hear anything
didn't hear anything and then he soared
right behind us and we turned around and
managed to find him but I'm just gonna
turn off yet has he sent marks hope he's
gonna soar for us again but you could
see how long the grass is how tricky it
is to actually see these guys when
they're in the long long grass they
coats are just so well designed for
blending in hello boy it's been a long
time since we've seen them shame I know
only has been looking for her camera he
says he hasn't seen how come we're yet
and he was looking for him this
afternoon so it's a bit sad that only
wasn't close otherwise I would have told
him to come here so you I may have a
little look it's always nice when all of
us get to see you know these lipids
because they're incredible animals and
obviously when you've never seen certain
individuals you kind of want to I mean
it's much like me with Sabri
I really want to see her but in time it
will happen I mean she one day I'd say
but I'm gonna try get around him so he
can get his face rather than his bottom
do a little on the clothes side at the
moment so let's just give him a chance
to get forward a bit before we finish up
our day what a nice way to finish a last
minute lipid isn't that exciting just
goes to show you see what happens when
we watch a little bit of a lightning
storm and is that you can get yourself
into a position to hear what's going on
and to be able to then find him in oh
you heard him from a long way away I
mean where we were convinced where we
are now is not close it took us a bit of
racing as you all saw to kind of get to
where we need to be and it seen use my
spotlight to see where he is
in relation to us is that that Bush they
said so I've got some time to turn which
is nice this is like extreme off-roading
that we've got to do mrs. Anna you say
look at that wobbly Bailey oh I can't
see a thing
to try and not crash as we go back onto
the road okay I'm just gonna give us
solve some distance a sip can get a nice
shot of him coming towards us there we
go don't get an anxiety mo we're all
good now
there we go sip that's quite nice he'll
be walking kind of straight towards us
at this stage
definitely hokum or you can see by the
tongue being out and the highs as sip
says he's gonna st. mark and I'm pretty
sure he'll come back towards the road
we'll probably find that he'll kind of
move in our direction now I'm going to
turn off my headlight so that I don't
blind him as you can see he's kind of
twitching his eyes a little bit
I'm going to the infrared instead isn't
that cool
hello boy you know well since I've seen
you just keep going back sip say isn't
that cool what a way to finish don't you
think I think so I'm sure everybody is
pretty happy that we managed at least to
get some spots for the first time in a
few days it's been I think the last
spots we had was to garden with you and
Steve said which is not ideal right
let's just go back a little further and
then we should get a really nice kind of
finishing up sort of view of him kind of
coming down the road towards us further
we go see you Rick and we've got the
timing right I don't know I think we
might be Archer let's see how we go we
gotta time it for a minute but I think
he's gonna be on top of us before
minutes is art the way he's walking but
let's just give it a chance but I love
the way that he walks with his tongue
out and his kind of
exit sort of cheeks that he's got his
typical hooker Murray pose as he kind of
walks down the road towards us they said
we've definitely not squandered we're
not going to make a minute that's for
sure he was getting closer right so we
have to go back again look good morning
what are you doing so late you're not
allowed to come in to the property
lights and he's just crossed in because
we're right up against the sort of
western boundary at this stage so there
we go
I'll just stop you and see what he get
up to I don't know him I think he's
going to come past us before 30 seconds
is that but it is that time of the day
where we need to say goodbye to all of
you hopefully you've had a wonderful
evening with us as we've seen all kinds
of interesting and unique things and
hopefully we will see you all tomorrow
afternoon remember tomorrow notes drive
tomorrow morning so see you in the
afternoon bye for now
[Music]